she lovely in red we have registered
dietitian Abby sharp here today to talk
in general terms about making healthy
food choices right absolutely you know
we got through this terrible winter
alive thank goodness and spring tons
here and everyone's talking about spring
cleaning right yes for spring cleaning
our homes our wardrobes I thought why
not sprinkling are eating habit right
good point because i intend to we tend
to gravitate to stuff that just is
comfort food makes us feel good exact in
the moment exactly we gotta get out of
that in the winter to exactly so easy
tips & tricks no dieting you're gonna
love it okay alright so first of all
though I want you to reconsider
completely shake things up alright so
first of all I like to think about my
body kind of like a car and I'm a
Ferrari a red one oh yes you are exactly
so if I'm a car that my hunger is like
my gas tank and I will be you and my mom
always said you don't want to wait until
you're running on fumes before you fill
up your tank right because when you do
that that's when you have to go to that
really seedy gas station you hate or the
more the really high prices you limit
your choices right that's true you reach
for whatever's handy handy what we do
this all the time with our eating habits
right we wait till we're super starving
then we binge on everything and
everything we see until they're so full
we need to unbuckleour belt buckles
right so today instead I wanted to start
thinking about always staying between
about corner and three quarters of the
way full all right and not give you some
buffer so that you can make healthier
more mindful choices about what to eat
rather than those frantic ones so the
there's nothing here right now that's
good for me I'm not starving so I can
wait till I get home or whatever exactly
so first things first though we got to
start things off on the right foot with
some good for you breakfast yeah and you
know I like to think you don't want to
leave the garage the garage without some
good feel in your body so our purple
sprinkles healthier than blue sprinkles
well we're not even gonna go there we're
gonna work on my pumpkin pie oatmeal
okay so it sounds really decadent but
it's actually super healthy and it's a
slow cooker recipe so it's really great
you know you throw it all in the night
for you wake up it's all good for you
you wake up to that nice and roll most
pumpkin pie it's perfect yeah so uh and
this is the moulinex volker it's a
the great brand French brand I got four
8999 so you don't need to spend a whole
lot of money to really be able to put
something like this together cool + pop
in the dishwasher easy-to-make
easy-to-clean so if i can get your help
if you want to pour in a cup and a half
of steel cut oats and steel cut oats are
the ones where they've kind of chopped
them up they're not well right it
doesn't look like the rolled oats that
were used to and we're going to do four
and a half cups of water but I like the
steel cut oats because they're high in
fiber and protein then you're kind of
quick cooking out is this your water you
pop it all in and they're chewier so you
get better or you feel like you got more
mouth you do it's got a nice nutty
texture and this is the secret
ingredient so if you want to pour that
in that's a cup of pumpkin puree it's
really high fiber so it's surprise I
know it's crazy so this is what it is
pumpkin puree you want to make sure not
to get the pumpkin pie filling which has
all the extra sugar in it the progress
the pumpkin just plain pumpkin and then
I'm just gonna season up a little pinch
of salt some vanilla of course that adds
some nice flavor and this is the pumpkin
pie spice that was gonna add that
beautiful aroma oh that smells amazing
right so literally put the top on six to
eight hours or however long sleep and
you're gonna wake up it's all ready for
you I just taught my little bit skim
milk for some extra protein there it is
um some simply got a nice little bit of
maple syrup you want sweetness and some
toasted almonds it's gonna get that nice
little crunch and some good for you fats
and so filling so filling and that's the
thing because you really gotta think
about having breakfast because when you
skip breakfast you go for that mid
morning crash and what are you gonna go
for the sprinkles you're going to go for
the bagels the pastries the doughnuts
whatever it is at that CD gas station
and I all wanted to avoid you almost
can't help it your body compels you
comprise you want to go straight for
that yeah whereas if you've set it up in
advance with a healthier meal you're
only as good as your last meal only it's
good and it's not a very efficient fuel
but this combination of fiber of healthy
fats and protein is really going to get
you to your next meal or snack excellent
so let's talk about snacks because all i
think about snacks is kind of like my
spare tire okay you don't leave your
house i think or spare tire because when
you do that's when you get in trouble
with the vending machine or you come
home from work and you're so famous you
go straight for the bag of potato chips
and you're a prep through this puppy but
you need something that you can throw in
your purse it's going to be portable
exactly and there's two things I like to
think about when it comes to hell
snacks the food itself and how you eat
it so first of all I always recommend
going for foods that have no more than
about 200 a l'heure ease and again like
the oatmeal had that combination of fat
of healthy fat protein and fiber so
these are my to go tues I have an ounce
or a little handful of almonds or if you
want to count them through 23 or some
hummus with some nice veggies and and
the the funny thing is though cuz even
really healthy snacks like hummus leave
you have not such great choices though
when you're mindlessly eating them right
in front of the TV or in front of it or
out of the box or out of the bag right
how many times have you sat down from
the TV and had a healthy snack like
hummus and you just sold your show you
just blast right through it tell it's
true right the specific yeah you haven't
put an amount down for everybody else
and you finish off so I always say you
know transfer your own portion to a
little bowl or plate with little baggie
I loved individual sized portions this
is super cute this little tin it just
holds an ounce of almonds I pop this
into my bag it's so cute I pop it into
my purse and I know at 3pm when I'm
feeling a little dip I'm good to go so
and you don't even have to count you
just fill them fill this up and it's the
perfect it's perfect I I can't live
without these snack size baggies they're
the best say the best so we let's move
on to mealtime cuz i would say the same
way you plan for your snacks you've got
a plan for your meals cuz if you don't
5pm comes along you don't have a dinner
plan oh who are you gonna call yep your
favorite delivery guy okay so I say you
know on your day off spend little time
planning out your meals for the week and
coming up with a categories grocery list
so this is my grocery list it's got all
the categories just based on how I know
my favorite grocery stores organized and
it's great this is not only going to
save you kind of calories and cash by
avoiding that takeout call but it's also
going to help you control those impulse
buys when you know you're at the store
and you see that the cookie is on sale
for sampling them god forbid and you're
like oh I think I'd go for cookies but
clever right and that's not to say you
can't have your cookies or whatever your
little your tree is like you can see I
put ice cream on my list it's always
there but it just means you gotta be
like it doesn't go on the list you
probably don't want or need it that much
so you don't put it in the cart what
have you got here you've got meals that
look very similar I
so let's move on to portions because
it's really tricky I say a really great
way to reduce your portion sizes without
ever thinking about it is to swap your
your big size plates for smaller size
sets okay so that's what's different
exactly so you can see I mean if you
were to we've got two different portions
here if you were to be served this
portion on this plate you probably be
very satisfied looks like a big hurry go
what all this is so much food but if you
were to visit up the same portion on
this plate he'd be like where is the
food that's just not enough so what are
you gonna do you're probably going to
top it up even more even more and so the
amazing thing is just take a peek at
these numbers though because this
portion here five on our calories very
reasonable for a meal but if you were to
top up and top up just to fill up that
extra white space you could be taking in
like 800 hours twice as many calories
and the plate size made all this all
these are tricking our eyes all the
difference makes and that's really what
it comes down to with a minute a half
before we go to break up same thing with
the cereal cereal but you know what I
always say when it comes when it comes
down to it regardless of what plates
nice you choose I say you're in a good
shape as long as you feel about half
your plate with your veggies so you can
see lots of veggies half your tag of
veggies a quarter with your green and
starch so you know your potatoes or rice
your pasta and then a quarter with your
meat or your your you know your tofu
your chicken and your beans yep and when
you think of it like that you know
especially the small plate it's really
easy to appreciate it you can't put a
big 12 at stake on your plate because
there's not enough room for this good
for you vegetables that are really going
to help you drive up all that nutrition
and reduce the overall calorie counting
your meal so the bowl size is similar is
it the same amount of same amount of SD
MMC really I would want to pour more
cereal yes you would of course you it
looks like a little and same with a
glass you've done it with everything
yeah I mean think about that you're not
gonna just fill your glass halfway right
but this glass looks full hell and good
to go I do that I trick my daughter like
that with with fruit juice yeah cuz I
she wants to drink a big glass shoes and
I want her to drink a little bit yeah so
I use smaller glasses and what they
can't complain he filled the class where
that's all you're not normally good
points okay she's gonna stick around
we're gonna have more with Abby after
the break stay tuned the
late sighs you know you might as well
you should be eating off our salad place
sting we treasured mommy I wanted to our
Sophia but it's not on are you sure I
think you may have missed a channel
right now you'll find the new kid zone
on channel two hundred or Rogers
anyplace TV your kids can watch all
their favorite shows from home or on the
go and it's already included in your
cable package this is awesome check out
Rogers Kid Zone on channel two hundred
or log onto Rogers anyplace TV com we
really like Easter Toronto beaches lions
easter parade sunday april twentieth on
rogers TV in ontario it's the law if
you're under the age of 22 and you're
driving you can't have any alcohol to
drink 0 that's 0 not o not nothing so
check not a drop it means no beer no
wine no shots coolers even a set no
alcohol end of story if you're the age
of 22 and you're driving forget the
boots zero tolerance for alcohol and
drivers under the age of 22 let's keep
our roads safe
hi I'm Val coal from daytime corrado for
everyone here at Rogers TV thank you to
our hard-working volunteers for National
Volunteer Week whether you're a camera
operator a makeup artist or you're
running the audio board you make us look
and sound great thank you
registered dietitian Abby sharp is here
before the break we were talking about
how plate size can make a huge
difference in how much you actually end
up eating and you said you even use a
smaller fork seriously you can see the
difference between a you know a solid
pork and you know your regular meat fork
but this is going to put lots less on
your on your plate so you end up taking
longer to eat your food absolutely
because you're having smaller bites
that's so clever you use the salad fork
you shovel it looks better too if you're
sitting with the date good point hey we
can go your website and get great tips
all the time what else do you do on your
website oh yeah lots of great recipes
cooking tips healthy eating tips I also
you'll find me going up out in about
town I review all the greatest
restaurants and go to all the food
events so if you're a food lover you
definitely got to check out Abby's
caption calm a food lover who all is
also interested in the in healthy food
absolutely and I don't think that you
know healthy food needs to mean boring
bland you know a diet food I think
there's really room for kind of
appreciating the pleasure of eating and
yeah well you got to get the restaurants
just to start serving our food on
smaller plate that's that's my next goal
okay it's a revolution Asian smaller
forks too I often eat with a salad fork
but only because there aren't any other
clean ones yeah but now I'm going to do
it for on purpose Abby's kitchen calm
great tips thank you thank you still to
come on the show today why we are going
to be here